still too slow to catch me
i'll
be sitting in bed one can like you still
won't catch me up
[Music]
what is happening people i am paddy the
baddie and i'm here to answer the
internet how many grown men would it
take to kill a grizzly player with their
beards one me end of
i'll [ __ ] double leg him elbows
facing for him he wouldn't like to take
the hamlet i'd [ __ ] his [ __ ] off if
every time you finish this sex a song
plead what would you want it to be
you'll never walk alone [ __ ] right
you [ __ ] know that you'll never walk
alone we will never walk alone how long
would it take you to eat your own body
weight and hot dogs i'm a fat [ __ ] i'd
show it on all um at the minute i'm a
bit fat love i'm about 85 key so 85 keys
worth of hot dogs
it's taken me a good few hours that take
me at least six to 12 hours though what
is 85 keys 85 keys like 190 pounds 190
all right how much do you think a hot
dog weighs
half a pound something no way hot dogs
are like 10 ounces
let's let's
find out what our dog is let's see how
many off dogs it works outer ten hot
dogs is one pound ten hot dogs just one
pound yeah
and now i'm lost on the map so uh no no
right there just 190 times ten that's
one thousand nine hundred dogs yeah i'll
do that in 24 hours
[Laughter]
if you're born with action figure hands
stuffing seems to be forever
oh i'd need my answer just be like that
but then like life's [ __ ] i can't even
hold that can't eat nothing yeah you
have to get me beds to feed me you
wouldn't be able to grapple be on the
floor like that grabbing all the people
putting me hands together like that but
i'd have to have them like that's
[ __ ] punch people on the face
otherwise it just doesn't work
that's an easy one yeah it is dana i can
just slap everyone over one
across the face
well there's one thing that someone can
say that makes you immediately hate them
they deep this one but anyone that
[ __ ] says anything about like
liverpool anything what happened then
[ __ ]
back back in the day glad anyone has to
call anyone from liverpool or victim
i'll [ __ ] kill you i'll kill you
is that what guys you kicked off twitter
yeah someone's had to say like liverpool
fans of victims are this and that which
it goes back to something different
and i just called them a fat ugly [ __ ]
and swifter took me account of me
yeah get the [ __ ] out they call the
targeted harassment and bullying when i
was i said was your father glee
[Laughter]
[ __ ] madness
if you could be the paint and sing to
someone what would it be i'd be the pete
and say they're getting skinny and then
getting fat because it's what i do
allowed to go skinny then go fast
skinny fat skinny fat if you could get
one movie called tattooed on your body
what would it be
well i just because i watched it the
other day goodwill
where [ __ ]
what does robin will william say to him
i've got to go and see about a girl
it's a sick
oh and then there's matt damon satay
james bond or jason bourne i'd go with
jason bournemouth because he's a more
rugged rebbe [ __ ] even as even
as a brit no [ __ ] britain
debate the intent yeah taken hostage
five years ago what would surprise you
the most about the world today how much
of a gang of mushrooms facebook and
instagram have turned into on twitter
because they're [ __ ] scared you can't
hold on a fat [ __ ] no more
i could say what you wanted five years
ago couldn't you thirty
four kill getting the win knocked out
yet dead leg nut top there's no tack
getting it in the balls yeah kill killer
maddie dead legend [ __ ] get in the wind
knocked out here that's horrible as well
getting the wind knocked are you getting
the wind knocked darley is horrible a
lot but getting it in the balls when you
get the balls it just hurts when you get
the winner you think you're gonna die
yeah you're like
i thought it's like you feel like you've
just wanted and you're doing a film and
you're just like being gasping for there
in the sea
the nice thing about regular adults is
we don't get to win knockouts anymore
yeah you still do yeah you're right i
still get it every now and then when
people land on me this question kind of
perfectly applies to you
if you're a professional athlete well
take the piece of their career and you
won the powerball would you keep playing
or take your winnings and decide i keep
playing me i'd have just basically won
the powerball anyway bastilles have
sponsored me no i mean i'm [ __ ] nice
and i'm still fighting because you get
600 million dollars and and i'd still
fight yeah
yeah just because i like punching people
in the face would you add the world lost
women or all sports
it's a mess you wanna be heavy living
without footy and mma not saying that
that's my career as well it's not just
[ __ ]
it's not just a sport but like
floor it'll go bananas if i don't say
women
so i'm going to go with sport
would you rather be the best looking
dude in the world or be able to read
man's read minds therefore we demand to
be sick anyone can be [ __ ] good
looking if i can read what you're
thinking you're dead you'll rather be
[ __ ]
like why what'd you just say
my head was thinking he's got some good
eyes on him yeah you know that the blue
eyes and the blonde did he wake up
if you're made it who'd be the most
likely suspect me misses probably
i annoy you that much now and then she'd
probably be allowed to stab me if you
could have an endless supply of anything
what would it be can you say money did
you save money that's an easy one money
not money trying to think of something
expensive i could sell for money
loads of boxes of cocaine
get loads of money off that
that coca-cola i love cherry coca-cola
if i could have an endless supply of
that i'd be living which fictional
college would love to beat the [ __ ] out
of probably say joffrey joffrey yeah
joshua
i'm glad i've had that major chance
ramsay ramsey he's another [ __ ] he's a
very good actor
very good
if you're reading the story of your life
and you got to the present day would you
keep reading on you can't change
anything you read that's a proper ad on
that i'll probably read on them you
agree on
you're like one of those paid like when
netflix you know it's three o'clock in
the morning
yeah i keep watching yeah i keep
watching the next episode until i fall
asleep that's almost pissed me off about
america i was watching this channel the
other day called amc
i'm like i swear to god i have never
seen so many commercials in my [ __ ]
life lad i felt like throwing the remote
at the telly
every two minutes there was an advert at
the end of the film there was a [ __ ]
gun scene we were fighting shooting at
each other and it just cut out and went
to an advert
so he [ __ ] tell he's out loud would
you rather fight my tyson sound like him
for the rest of your life well he's like
50 something now any so i'll fight him
obviously he'll punch me [ __ ] head
right in but he doesn't know what it's
coming when i shoot him
i don't care if it's a boxing match i'll
be like [ __ ] the kid in rough and
ready rough and rowdy he's only done the
double leg lad and he was getting beat
abby just did exactly that me lad
dropped my crown on his head would you
box him in like one of those exhibition
matches yeah that'd be sick that'd just
be be an honor because it might taste
like
would you rather
oh pardon me
would you rather
it's on the floor like was
before you within a fight 10
10 10 year olds or 100
year olds it's gotta be the hundred
hundred year olds on it it's 110 like
that numbers don't lie
numbers don't lie but the kids are
faster
haven't even got the strength yet he
can't even throw a proper punch he's
still in a little school
not even a big boy yeah
an under-year-old is [ __ ] your [ __ ]
up if there was a snail following you
for the rest of your life and if you
took and if you touched it you'd die how
long did you survive
my whole life on [ __ ] slugs catching
me a lot he'll get on planes to follow
you everywhere you go this this snail is
following you so when you rest your eyes
at night yeah that snail is still too
slow to catch me
i'll i'll be sitting in bed wanking like
he still won't catch me up
now that is a hard one
bacon or sausage
that's an odd one this is the biggest
one lad this is toffee depends what
sausages they are i'd say bacon nonsense
out of 10 but if these sausages from
asda what are caramelized onion sausages
lad i'm going with the sausage
so caramelized onions
the power sausage [ __ ] with them on
some cheese
[Music]
heavy
so like that one i am proper torn i
don't um
[ __ ] i'm gonna go bacon but not american
bacon cause you're baking [ __ ]
proper bacon real bacon that's not half
fat
so yeah baby
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell
comment who you want to see do it and
watch all the other answer the internets
i don't know where anything is so i'm
kind of just moving my hands around but
do all that [ __ ] subscribe comment
reminder watch others you're welcome
don't know why but you're welcome